a long time ago there was a production
in our place that left a kino uh light
plate
and sam attached it to attack vest
and made this pvc rig for gopro and now
we have a sweet third-person camera rig
that's how it
happened you can't see the rig right
no awesome okay so
we'll be cutting so it would be like
drag cut a little farther along a little
you know just to make it just people
don't care
that like those little things aren't one
shot obviously like a couple of them
will matter but most of them
on top of it's just sliding
cool you guys really just sliding in the
shot it's awesome all right i shouldn't
swear as much as i'm making ups
hey here nico
fred you want to help me instead of niko
also make it move
look
still water
we'll cut on like the boring move parts
so we get you like hiding and creeping
and that's like important here okay all
right sure all right
we're doing a third person video
ready
and action
you're hitting his hand down away
and even when you throw him into the
wall he's going to sell a lot of the
action got it even stepping in and going
like that then coming around and grab
you guys
and then go right around and just jump
right around him grab him yeah
yeah all right or actually no actually
i'll drop you like this i'm just gonna
go like
and then i'm gonna like this
i'm walking this way you guys are
walking to the bar
so guys welcome to the bar i'm gonna get
shot by this guy infiltrating this art
gallery
he's gonna come around the corner you're
gonna be here it's gonna form
pop
strip
one two three grab the gun as he goes
now
action
[Music]
hey what's up man
slowly
yeah
no
no we're not doing this goddammit niko
why don't we pull this back this way
this is [ __ ] dude
no it's gonna go great
all right here we go
[Music]
here's what i'm thinking let's go you
odd for blocking we have one shot you
can out the door
[Music]
and then
he starts picking up the minigun because
that's going
and there's a guy running up
[Music]
then he cuts a third-person camera
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh
you spin around
i missed it because i was acting nico
what you got to do
i'm about to give the rope to somebody
else who's going to pull this guy
we got to pull his ass
hq fishing all over
hey guys i just want to say big thanks
to the thousand pounds fighting company
chris here is amazing at shooting action
james who did some awesome choreography
sale helped him out to some sweet stunts
haley here just helped out it's pretty
sweet
and you know what i also want to say
thanks to evik for loading us this mini
gun because it's super cool
no
anyways
what's your what's your youtube channel
uh youtube rhythm x3i
yeah
okay
you guys want to check out some other
sweet fight scenes i've done go to
youtube.comrivenx3i i'll spell it on the
screen so you guys can just click on
that instead all right well it was
really cool we're gonna get out of here
before we get in trouble for being on
this roof
brett what's up not a whole lot sam
thanks brad for shooting the behind the
scenes
[Music]